girl ain't asked for help one time y'all
want lines to front y'all work I was on
the front line talking about who you
gonna find man you ain't getting far
putting ten dollars on pump nine my dope
make fiends on one if they don't want
dimes we serve trades like the lunch
line now calm down I brought one I'm
with your wife we having a fun time to
the sunshine
a gun Crown we all got 50 shots and
I Glock now that's a drumline drug
dealer was a dumb ground I realized I
could make brick money off one rhyme I
tried to help some clown but when you're
deaf and dumb the next step to become
blind you stink with a young mind
the only reason you don't like your life
is cause you want mine in the garage
where the Porsche is put new GT3 come
see how 500 horses look I got an office
with a softness cup only hire certain
people I'm real cautious from the losses
took you know when I caught a crook his
wife was pregnant and he didn't get to
see how his daughter look bring me
his head on a hook